I was on Ivermectad through another practitioner this winter I tolerated it
well and tell she doubled the dose and I broke out in a three-week itchy
rash that stopped and stopped the Ivermectad could this be good to be back on
it for me though a lower dose certainly it can be with any thing you could take
too much you could overwhelm your pathways if you broke out an itchy rash I
know somebody else and you're having issues with an itchy rash I wouldn't like to
know how that is going for you to it can be just because you're just kind of
overwhelmed in your body you can you know sometimes you need to take a break
from something Ivermectad is a drug and you have to detoxify it so that could
be the issue oh that was about fasting another person okay good I will set up a
call with ready to go over my situation this week thanks for help absolutely
we know sugar from alcohol could feed cancer cells but we know that red wine
can be an antioxidant right so we should all drink at least two bottles of wine
at a day but yeah you can't argue the fact that a good clean wine can be
beneficial you know there's a story circulated around on Instagram right
now about somebody did a little short video on the guy who had terminal lung
cancer that he was given just months to live and told him he had to go on
keyboard therapy and stuff and he decided forget it I'm gonna move back to my
hometown which is a Greek island off the in the Mediterranean he moved back to
that Greek island just to die and he ended up living in other 20 years or
something like that crazy crazy story I've talked about that story years ago
I think might even wrote about his story in my book I don't remember and
he drank wine every day and just totally clean living all organic food zero
stress all sorts of things contribute to one's healing so everything with
moderation is the right way to go